sadly Missy is a cosplay I have yet to
acquire
[Applause]
[Music]
all right back to Big Finish and now I'm
gonna talk about the other box set that
I picked up while I was like Gallifrey
won back in February before we were all
forbidden to leave the house and that is
Missy series 1 now because the other one
that I picked up at the time was the war
doctor series 1 and I listened to that
one first and was very much disappointed
by that I wasn't entirely sure of what
to expect from Missy series 1 I'd kind
of had my expectations cushioned
thankfully I didn't really have to worry
how much better comparison is definitely
the War Master series one
although the tone is distinctly
different but definitely in terms of
overall format that is four stories more
or less independent or more accurately
three stories more or less independent
and then a fourth story that sort of
picks pieces from the previous three and
brings it together for a little
conclusion concluding thing although
interestingly even the fourth one is
pretty self-contained until he gets to
the very end and starts tying the
threads together so it's structurally if
there's a lot closer resemblance to the
war master than it did the war doctor
and for me that's a good thing I found
the war master a heck of a lot more
inventive and exciting whereas the war
doctor I found to be annoyingly
predictable and this definitely is not
that now
here's the main thing you need to keep
in mind tone wise this stuff is
borderline parody comedy each of these
stories is very much taking a jab at
some style of storytelling and it is
very much done in a light-hearted way
the first story is very much a take on
Mary Poppins Missy literally becomes the
governmentís of two young children and
takes them out on adventures
then the second story it has the
meddling monk in it and that becomes a
much more of a sort of arguing buddy
dynamic sort of thing the third story is
a complete and total take off unlike
really bad true crime programs you know
the really overdone with the recreations
with actors and like but it's there's a
narration saying the thing that you're
seeing and then you see and then the
narrator reiterates again like
completely going nuts with that and then
the last one sort of it takes the
longest to figure out what is Missy up
to with this although that is actually
an element to all three of these stories
you don't really know what Missy's up to
Missy is at the heart of all four of
these stories and the thing that's fun
about that is we're not with her the
whole way we are usually starting out
with other characters and then Missy
shows up and we're left as listeners
wondering what are you up to and here's
what I really love about this the whole
thing overall it really very well
understands how Missy is different from
other incarnations of the master while
not forgetting the things that still
make her an incarnation of the master so
when you're dealing with incarnations of
the master especially they're gonna base
the story around them then you're
largely gonna be dealing with scheming
plan making grand visions for universal
conquest sort of deals and we pretty
much got that with the the war master
with a little bit in there of he's kind
of on the back foot you know trying to
avoid being sucked into the time war
again now with Missy she is scheming but
she has way more fun than pretty much
any other master ever did that's not to
say that the master never had fun before
but generally if the master ever had fun
it was either in the glee of what he
thought was gone
happen if he succeeded or in tormenting
the doctors specifically at least
personally I didn't necessarily get a
sense that the master always took Glee
and all elements of what he was doing
but with Missy oh yeah
she's gonna have fun while she's at this
you had a little of that with the John
Simm master but with Missy it is all out
and that is sort of what she brings to
the table with that incarnation of the
master a much higher emphasis on her
having fun which because of her whims
and what she considers fun at any given
moment also makes her much less
predictable which I really really enjoy
pretty much all the other masters the
only thing that makes them unpredictable
is whether or not you can figure out
what planet is they are trying to
execute once you understand what they're
trying to do the Masters actions are
pretty easy to suss out Missy you could
know what she's after and still be like
I don't know what she's gonna do next
and I love that it is so much fun
Michelle Gomez is clearly having an
absolute blast at this especially when
she gets to do these horrible fake
accents she gets to do it in two
different stories in the third one and
the fourth one oh my god it's so bad
like on purpose purposefully gloriously
bad and she pretends to be someone else
and does these insane accents oh god
it's so good so if I were to look at
each and each story individually I
really do enjoy them all and it's hard
for me to pin down a favorite it may be
the third one which is the detective
crime story pastiche only because it's
so meta and it surprisingly like when it
started and when I started to get the
sense of how Missy fit into this and how
it was gonna play out I was like are
they gonna try and justify this in
universe for how this is playing out
because you know there's so much fourth
wall breaking in this
I don't think you justify that it might
just have to roll with it no they
actually find ways to sort of explain
and integrate and justify it which are
very cool and also there's a lot of just
neat twists and turns to that one and
and the meta nature of it especially you
yield some really good humor I think
behind that is the second one the one
with the meddling monk which first of
all the two of him anytime they're
talking to each other it is so good I
haven't I don't know with the meddling
monk has turned up another big finish
before if he has this is my first time
encountering him and he's so much fun
and I like that he's annoyed that he's
known as the meddling monk he starts
complaining about it when Missy
identifies him as bad it's like I
dressed up as a monk one time why how
can you keep going to that Missy's like
alliteration trumps accuracy oh that's
perfect his level of noise her level of
just flippant and although she needles
him because that that story is set in
the time of Henry the eighth and she has
so what you first landed here where did
you land was it a monastery and he's
it's it's great her just driving him
nuts and the two of them trying to
outwit each other because they both kind
of think they might need each other but
they also definitely don't trust each
other it's great it is such a I mean fun
fun is the word for this entire box set
I mean if I were gonna rank them over ma
I think it will probably put the third
one at the top then the second the
fourth and the first but it's not a huge
drop-off that's a pretty tight and like
even the first one is a lot of fun and
the other thing is that it does for all
the fun that it is that last one
especially even though it still keeps
some of the humor does a pretty good job
of reminding you that Missy is dangerous
that Missy is the master
that if having if keeping someone alive
doesn't make her feel like she's having
fun she is capable of monstrousness and
I really like that that was in there
because the the risk is always sort of
having too much fun and being too
light-hearted about a monstrous
character and that last story while
certainly not going as dark as something
like say the sky man from the the war
master box set is still really good and
when you get the full scope of what it
is she's doing how she's been going
about it and her endgame in all of it
yeah you're real you realize oh right
it's a bad idea to let our guard down
around you it's a it kind of serves in a
way the same purpose of her killing
Oswin I'm sorry not possibly Osgood I
always do that of her killing
Osgood and the reason that had to happen
was because she's so much fun you start
to forget that she's dangerous and so
the force and it was really good that
was the last story the last story as you
uncover the full nature of what it is
that she's been doing and the
callousness with which she's been doing
it you it starts the saying like oh
right he all he almost feel a little
guilty for having rooted for her up to
that point and you should and it's great
I'm not gonna go into spoilers really on
any of these because honestly I'm just
gonna recommend them just straight up
all the whole box set and the box sets
I'm usually hesitant to recommend
because they're expensive but this thing
is really really good and all the
supporting cast is great as well so the
ads even like I mentioned the the
highlight of the supporting cast is
easily the actor who's playing the
meddling monk in the second one and
especially he's
gets flustered when he knows he's in a
situation where like I don't think I can
talk my way out of this he gives us a
yeah and Western nervousness that I
really enjoyed and and it also does a
good thing with a way that built again
much like the war master in terms of
laying seeds in the first three that
don't feel like seeds at the time but
then all that gets harvested for the end
and actually I would say it actually
does that particular thing a little bit
better than the war master I keep
comparing it to that one it's hard for
me to say which is better because no
single story and this is better than say
the sky man from that previous war
master box at but I do think that the
overall experience of this and
especially the concluding part of it is
better and Missy series one than was in
in only the good the first war master
box set but they're both good and this
would this was fun this makes me want to
grab another series worth of Missy cuz I
god she's guys she's so much fun this is
just a rip-roaring good time Missy
series one Big Finish box set you listen
to it what you think about it if you
haven't what box sets would you
recommend that highlight either an
incarnation of the master or a villain
of some kind whatever your thoughts on
any of this is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it you can
help me out by supporting me on patreon
and you can also help out on here with
the usuals like subscribe that bell go
ahead hit that do all that there's also
links in the bottom click on those or
don't not gonna tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]